thank you everybody for coming this
afternoon
this panel discussion has really
sponsored by the brain hub which is a
initiative to bring together scientists
and engineers across campus who are
interested in brain function and today
we're going to talk about the
intersection between computer science
and neuroscience with the overall
question of how close are we to being
able to replicate human cognitive
functions in a machine and what do we
need to know from the biology to be able
to do that so I have four distinguished
panelists to introduce you to today
sandy Cullen who's mrs. a professor in
the Department of Biological Sciences in
the Center for the neural basis of
cognition she's been here for I think
almost four years three and a half years
now and she's using next-generation
approaches imaging large numbers of
neurons in the rodent neocortex she
studies visual system plasticity wayne
wu is the associate director of the
center for the neural basis of cognition
he's a philosopher of mind and his the
author of studies about schizophrenia
and auditory hallucinations as well as a
book about attention most recently dick
turetsky is a research faculty member in
the department of computer science and
his interests are in both computer
science and education as well as robots
and brains and on a day is the director
for the human-computer interaction
Institute in the department of computer
science so we're going to start off with
a brief introduction from each one of
our panelists about this question in
general and they have some audio-visual
aids to show you and then we'll discuss
some particular topics the last 15
minutes will be open for questions from
the audience and so if you think of
something during the course of our
discussion you know write it down and
and we'd love to take your questions
so sandy why don't I let you start off
Thank You Alison so I wanted to start
off by saying coming coming from the
point of view of brain function as a
biologist and so one of the reasons why
I love these types of discussions is the
brain is really complex it's made up
different cell types so just like we
have muscle cells bone cells that
perform different functions for example
your muscle cells move your skeleton
around and your whole body's held
together by skin cells the brain is made
up of these of different cells that
perform different functions so we know
that we also know that brain neurons are
connected to each other
some rain neurons are not connected to
each other so there's connections
synaptic connections between neurons and
also those synaptic connections can be
strong or weak so those are some
fundamental properties of brains that we
know and we know a whole bunch of other
properties about how proteins and
molecules function in individual neurons
given this complexity and kind of
thinking in terms of what can we learn
in our lifetime I'm actually a little
pessimistic that we can understand brain
function in our in our life so then the
best strategy for my point of view is
actually to come up with what are the
good strategies to understand the brain
and so as neuroscientists we're normally
open to new ways of thinking about
things in fact computational tools have
been very helpful and ultimately
algorithmic understanding of things that
look like consciousness could really
help my research but also you can think
of algorithm basis of consciousness as a
separate venue which I think we'll hear
from some of the other speakers so
there's kind of two purposes but they
might be synergistic so where are we at
in terms of biology and an algorithmic
understanding or computational
understanding very recently a paper came
out in Cell where a group in Europe
headed by Henry Markram has action is
actually attempting to simulate micro
circuits of the brain so they have a I
believe it's about 300,000 neurons that
they've digitally reconstructed and
built into a micro column and here you
can see they're looking at different
activities of these neurons - and
they're connected and they have synaptic
connections that they started
dissimulation with some basic rules and
understanding they had from experiments
and then they sort of let the algorithms
form the final connections and this is
this is the type of thing they come up
with like I said in the next movie we
can show the types of things that one
could do with such a simulation they can
actually activeness is a it's a sensory
part of the cortex that they're
simulating and they can essentially be
the same thing as wiggling the whisker
on a rodent and watch how the different
patterns of activity form so on that
initial wiggle you saw a burst of
activity and then sort of resonates
through the circuit and interestingly
just from this first implementation of
their simulation they they claimed they
made some discoveries that using their
algorithms the connections sort of look
like what we find in vivo and some of
the patterns of activity are actually
represented in from in vivo experiments
and that's very interesting because I
would suggest then that we know enough
of microcircuitry structure and that
some of that micro circuit connectivity
is actually sufficient to predict the
flow of neural activity powders in these
very limited micro circuits they also
realized that their simulation did not
recapitulate some of the activity
patterns we see in vivo and that is some
spontaneous shifts in between a
synchronized state and a synchronized
state which is very important for human
consciousness whether we're a sleeper
awake so when you're asleep you tend to
have synchronized activity when you're
awake it's less synchronized so we're
working needs to be done and they might
be adding different brain areas and
connections into that micro circuit
great thanks I'm gonna give it to Wayne
so can you put my slides up then so I
want to start off by just I really just
want to pose some problems and possible
solutions so go to the first slide there
the brain and mind number two number two
so this is a paper from Stennis left to
hain and shan-dro and what you're seeing
here is you know one of the model things
that we can do nowadays which is this we
have different ways of looking at brain
activity and here you are seeing a
difference the brain on the Left versus
on the right between in a subject who on
the in the left case here is a sound in
the right case does not now in the right
case you do see activity in the auditory
areas of the brain but the subject is
unconscious or he doesn't hear the sound
and so the slide is meant to demonstrate
something that's really difficult which
is how to understand how you go from
brain activity the generation of mental
states like auditory states of hearing
sound all right so on their review so
they have a theory of consciousness
which is called the work space theory
and the idea that they want to propose
is that what makes for consciousness is
that you broadcast this information
broadly into the brain and that's what
they're inferring from this really
brought broad activity if they're seeing
the brain but the issue really is well
why is that what generates consciousness
or auditory experience okay so it's not
that every kind of brain activity gives
rise to mentality to psychological
states all right so that's one question
that we have to ask we know that brain
activity is necessary and sufficient for
consciousness but not all forms of brain
activity are going to do it
this becomes hard then because on the
one hand we have neuroscientists who are
trying to understand the nature of brain
the circuits the physical electrical
properties the brain the informational
properties and if you want to them
bridge the gap to talk about say
artificial minds or downloading or
putting a mind into something like the
different physical structure on the
right side you're right how would you do
it okay so those are we already have
problems connecting the brain to the
mind and now they're gonna be additional
problems of connecting brain to machine
structures
and also machine structures in the mind
next slide please
how would you know that you've succeeded
so here is an intellectual hero to many
of us Alan Turing please advance and I
just want to remind you that in 1950 he
wrote this brilliant paper it's called
Computing Machinery and intelligence I'm
reproducing for you the first page he
proposed there in the first section of
the paper what's called the imitation
game what we now know as Touring's tests
and I reproduced the first sentence of
that paper
Turing's question can a machine think
next slide please
the beauty of Turing's work as men even
know his head he precisely defined the
notion of a machine for us which is this
idea of a digital computer or a training
next slide but the question of how do
you know whether or not you've succeeded
in producing in this case an artificial
mind nevertheless a mine where him was a
difficult question if you thought about
defining what thinking is philosophers
are really awful at definitions right so
how are you gonna do it this is the
brilliant move on his part
here's a test imagine on the left you
have a which is an artificial mind or
what purports to be on B you have and B
you have a real person and C's the
interrogator so the test of Turing
proposes as many of you know is that she
is going to figure out on the basis of
providing questions to A or B get those
answers back from them and assess on
that on the basis of that information
who is the human and for our purposes if
C is forced essentially guess in other
words if a really does a good job
simulating a mind then for Turing that
was essentially an affirmative answer to
his original question can machines think
sure and the point of bringing up this
test is that when we do all this sort of
complicated stuff I'm trying to
understand the brain looking at
different sort of circuits in the brain
trying to build an artificial mind
Turing provides I think a really
interesting test for how we might figure
out whether we've been successful or not
last slide and so that raises the
question whether or not this sort of
test is necessary sufficient if you
don't like this test and I suspect many
of you may not like this
asked what would you put in its place
I'll leave you with that question okay
can I have my first slide so artificial
intelligence is like flight people
dreamed of flight for thousands of years
and they made bird costumes they jumped
off cliffs that didn't do a whole lot of
good
but eventually technology advanced far
enough that we really can fly without
cheating and that's great
likewise people have dreamed for years
of making intelligent mechanisms but we
don't have the technology yet to do that
and so the next best thing we can do is
dress up in robot costumes for Halloween
or we can invent useful algorithms that
do some useful tasks and so well there
has never been an artificial
intelligence yet I don't I don't think
that they will never be one but we have
never seen one for real there have been
a lot of great successes in artificial
intelligence the field using specialized
algorithms for things like
game tree search information retrieval
speech recognition right your phone you
can talk to your phone now self-driving
cars are coming right so these are all
successes of specialized algorithms if
we can go to the next slide that's not
the next slide that's the next slide so
Watson who handily beat human players in
jeopardy is often held up as an example
of how much progress we've made in
artificial intelligence but Watson is a
collection of clever hacks that was
engineered by a team of multiple PhDs
who spent years getting this thing to
work and yet you cannot have a
conversation with Watson you can ask him
questions if they look like jeopardy
questions and he might say something
good or he might say something
completely stupid that a human would
never say depending on how good the
algorithm is so there's actually a whole
field of greasy hacks to pretend that we
have intelligence but we don't and
that's the loader prize which is using
these things called chat BOTS so this is
an attempt to pass the Turing test not
really it's an attempt to make us
pretend that we're passing the Turing
test by using greasy
haxe so you know here here are some of
the hacks right you can do this yourself
you have a prepared story that you
insist on telling whether the ear wants
to hear it or not you repeat things the
other person says whether or not you
understand them because it sounds like
you understand them and if all else
fails you evade their question by
changing the subject or asking them what
they think so if you if you read
Turing's paper and now if we can skip
ahead to slide 6 please so the paper
that Wayne showed you the cover page of
if you actually look at what Turing said
he gave a sample dialogue between an
interrogator and a computer and what
stands out is that the hypothetical
computer doesn't use any of these sleazy
hacks it's actually damn clever smarter
than your average undergraduate and so
you can see here when he talks about
this scanning of the sonnet and then he
switches to mr. Pickwick that's it
that's a Dickens character right so
we've got references to classic
literature and then he comes back and
tries this syllogism
Christmas is a winner's thing I don't
think mr. Pickwick with mine he's trying
to use a bogus argument he of faulty
syllogism and the computer comes back
and calls him on it and says you can't
be serious and it explains exactly why
the syllogism is wrong it doesn't evade
at all right this is what real
intelligence looks like nobody knows how
to do this and we probably won't in my
lifetime so in in my Institute in my lab
we focus a lot on understanding people's
behaviors and using technology to
understand people's behaviors and so
Dave posed the question I'm gonna get a
little bit off but he posed the question
you couldn't interrogate the which one
was that was it Watson that you could
you couldn't interrogate Watson you
couldn't ask it questions you couldn't
have a conversation with it and so in
following sort of what Wayne was saying
is that a reasonable test of whether
something is whether that's sort of
consciousness or AI so in my lab as I
said we focus on try to understand
people's behaviors through technologies
so if we could build at being a some
kind of form that could
the way your parent does let's take your
mother so walk the way your mother does
move the way your mother does speaks the
way your mother does would that be down
would that be at least a representation
our consciousness can you play the first
video this is sim say or new dimension
the first story the second one
not soon save the other one so this is
some work that was done by University of
Southern California remember it's in
Polish yeah don't judge yeah don't draw
a she's in a video Nia Morgan yeah keep
Ian ish yeah so the interesting thing
about this guy is that this is a real
personal this is a representation of him
there's a project oh you better cancel
that because I have no idea what's
coming up next you never know we gonna
get on YouTube so this is a project
University of Southern California where
they are trying to essentially capture
the life history of this gentleman who
survived the Holocaust and so it's some
work with the Shoah foundation and what
they're doing is they've got him in a
room and unders all sorts of different
lighting conditions that he can't even
perceive that there's different lighting
conditions so they can put different
backdrops behind him they're taking
cameras from multiple images so that
they can produce this 3d hologram what
you saw was an image of what that would
be like with the ability to ask it
questions so this was on The Today Show
just a few couple weeks ago where you
could where you know Matt Lauer
whoever's the guy on the Today Show now
could ask this gentleman a question it
was it was asking this repository of
information and what was really cool
about it was how that algorithm
underneath it could combine details from
a bunch of different responses he had
given sort of do the right head launched
at the right spot so that it had gave
you the impression that you were talking
to this guy now you know none of the
people that were interacting with him
knew he knew him personally so that it's
not so clear whether this is would be a
very good representation but at least
it's a start of something that you could
converse with we'll just play just a
tiny bit of the next one
this next one is some work done by hi
I'm Ellie thanks for coming in today I
was created to talk to people in a safe
and secure environment so she's a
virtual I'm not a therapist but I'm here
to learn about people and would love to
learn about you I would she says I got
started
the facial please for free news tell me
anything your answers are
interpretations she's gonna make you're
gonna showdown are you doing here okay
with this yes so how are you doing today
I'm doing well that's good
where are you from originally it's a
little awkward I'm from Los Angeles oh
I'm from LA myself when was the last
time you felt really happy when was the
last time so the idea here is that you
have this there this virtual therapist
not so great but a virtual therapist
that uses a lot of Technology cameras
microphones a lot of Technology looking
at the facial features the weight the
body pose any eye contact with you and
this virtual therapist is reacting in
real-time to that what the person on the
other side is saying so there's a
question there of whether these created
essences these created creatures are in
some way a form of AI or at least a our
important step to AI great so I want to
tease out something between on earth and
date here because in some ways what
you're saying is it doesn't really
matter if it's intelligent and in fact
maybe most of us wouldn't really
generate you know what it's considered
to be you know really deeply intelligent
comments and most of our daily
interactions as long as we seem like
we're making the right answer responding
the right way you know providing the
right responses maybe that's enough so
Dave what's the challenge here when
would you be satisfied with that sort
of approximation well it depends on the
task so I'm not a therapist but in grad
school my roommates were therapists and
so they were therapist in training and
so one thing I learned is that a major
part of therapy is forming a supportive
relationship with another person and so
even if the Machine was able to say all
the right things if you didn't feel that
you were relating to a person you may
not get the benefits but the other the
other issue I think is that this is a
pretty shallow interaction right so you
can you can make a script to handle a
lot of shallow interactions like you
want to book a table at a restaurant or
you're introducing yourself to a new
person in this case the therapist but
you're going through the standard
introductory monologue that's fine right
but if you've been in therapy for six
months or six years your therapist had
better have a lot of insight into your
personal beliefs and belief system and
history and they're not if they could do
that they'd be passing the Turing test
right they're not he's you know this
video he's showing you the first two
minutes right I don't want to know what
the next five hours looks like it's
gonna go bad real fast and then you're
then you're back at the Loebner prize
level Wayne Orana do you want to respond
to that so yeah I definitely don't
disagree with what Dave said so this was
meant to be provocative I certainly
don't wouldn't use that since since
sensei as my personal therapist but I do
think it really highlights this
interesting point of how real does
something have to be in order for you to
in order for you to at least go beyond
that sense of I don't want to interact
with this thing it's just fake I'm
kidding and and from their studies and
from their papers that they published in
fact one of the authors of this work is
now a faculty member in LTI and lpmorin
see sort of language technologies
instituted here at Carnegie Mellon and
the the papers that they write seem very
compelling to me in terms of how people
are willing to sort of throw away their
sense of disbelief and actually start to
interact with these with these with
these spiritual therapists or these
virtual characters and at
the sensitive USC is amazing because
they do stuff in with the military and
trying to do a cultural do cultural
awareness for our armed forces who are
all over the world and so they're able
to get everyday people to sort of throw
away that sense of disbelief and start
engaging and interacting and feeling
immersed in these kind of environments
and they do say you know the first thing
she said was I am NOT a therapist right
and so the whole point of this was
actually to do sort of early screening
or early detection if there's a problem
so I do think that as dave said for
certain tasks these things definitely
have their place I might just add to
that that the issue about tasks is
really important so if you go back to
Turing's test I mean that's a you might
think that's a really high bar right
being able to carry on this conversation
where you can really trick you know a
smart person on the outside
interrogating or being a good therapist
and you might say well maybe the way
that we should approach these problems
is to have a sort of more narrow of you
so maybe what we should try and do is
just emulate any kind of therapist even
bad therapist right I mean if you could
emulate a bad therapist and you
recognize it bad therapist that would be
some achievement maybe it would be a lot
easier than emulating a good one right
so how do you define your problems if
you're going to go into this business of
trying to figure out how say the brain
gives rise to the mind or how you might
produce an artificial mind having maybe
there may be the approach in response to
these I think correct worries is just to
kind of limit the goal in some ways
right but you don't to go too far right
as you might say well if I've created
some kind of visual detector I've I've
simulated really bad vision doesn't seem
right I mean your cameras then come your
iPhone camera comes across as a kind of
yeah bad a bad seeing thing right so so
how do you negotiate that I think that's
one of the issues probably that we would
have to if we think that the Turing test
is a bit too high of a par so Sandia I'd
like you to respond to this a little bit
because you know there's a lot of effort
that's going into reconstructing in
great detail the neural circuits of the
mammalian brain or particularly of the
rodent brain a billion euro project okay
so that's over 1 billion dollars and
hundreds and hundreds of computer
scientists and biologists are involved
in this endeavor do we need to know what
the biology is and how will the computer
scientists take the algorithms that we
learn to invoke more complicated
intelligent responses from an engineered
device do you wanna take the mic my
interest somewhat related to what I
think we've already heard here it
depends on the task and so we can have
very lofty goals like the big euro
project but in kind of a vacuum of not
having a task or a specific function
that you want that circuit to do you're
never going to probably reach a level of
satisfaction but if there's an agreement
on a specific task I'm actually fairly
optimistic so what's the task given what
we know with these very dense
reconstructions what's what's the task
that we can now simulate well at this
point I don't think we can simulate one
and that that is the challenge of you
know budding neuroscientist but what is
what is clear from a vantage point of
somebody doing lots of experiments is is
one key ingredient is and this also came
up in the simulations and in fact the
simulations that you saw a word from
this euro project is that one neuron
appears to partake in different ensemble
activities and this is something that we
also see in in the lab and so how do you
have this multiplexing of neural
function to understand that the next
thing we need to do experimentally is to
actually measure many behavioral
parameters at the same time so sort of
the ideal experiment right now in the
lab would be to image the animals like
foot pattern if he's walking get his
money behavioral readout says you could
while you're simultaneously imaging the
neural activity of and my favorite
scenario would be to find cell classes
as I spoke about and then put that
together and build simulations based on
that information and that might get you
even closer to some of the
so part of the this this question comes
up not only because of the enormous
investment but also this sort of
fanciful idea that perhaps if we knew
all the circuits all the wires then we
would be able to get closer to what
makes you you and Wayne Wayne and Dave
Dave etc so a few about a month ago
there was an article in The New York
Times about a young woman who had a
brain tumor and she is actually an
aspiring neuroscientist she'd applied to
a ph.d program in neuroscience and then
she found out she had this brain tumor
and she was gonna die and she decided
she wanted to fix her brain to prepare
it for potential electron microscope mic
microscopy for reconstruction so that
her brain would now be available for
understanding the specific circuits that
made her her and you know it was
incredibly poignant because I think many
biologists don't believe that we're
quite at that stage yet but she and her
her boyfriend really were sort of hoping
that they would get to talk again at
some time in the future do you guys want
to respond to that that possibility or
that that possibility now and that
future possibility so in other words the
idea of not replicating something that
seems like a person but seems like the
person that you knew and that has the
same recollections and the same
experiences that you've shared it's
going to defer to the neurophysiologist
but so this is really it's a
heartbreaking case because I think this
woman's hopes are really misplaced it's
it's virtually impossible that we had
the technology now to preserve a brain
well enough that you could slice it up
later and reconstruct everything you
would need to reproduce her her brain
structure in a way that it could be
single-a even had the ability to do the
simulation so you know when you die
stuff starts deteriorating pretty
quickly and then we have to go through
this preservation process and there are
still people working on preserving brain
tissue in ways that
doesn't destroy the tissue and they're
not there yet so they did the best they
could with her but it seems obvious to
me that her brain is just fried or
whatever you know use whatever cooking
metaphor you like freezer burn she's
ruined her brain is ruined and I turned
out the fixation it cost eighty thousand
dollars and the fixation was incomplete
yeah they blew the fixer that they did a
CT scan or an MRI and they found the
fixation only got 20% of the brain or
something 80 percent hadn't been fixed
properly but even if they hadn't done
that the current state of the art and
fixation is such that it's inconceivable
that so much information wasn't
destroyed by the fixation process to
bring her back but she's a special case
because she died of a brain disease as
opposed to dying of say a heart attack
where at least you have a normal brain
right but her she was losing brain
function even before she died because of
the tumor so to reconstruct her brain if
you may constructed it accurately you'd
be reconstructing somebody with us life
killing life-threatening brain tumor
right which may not be how they want to
go through eternity so what you really
want to be able to do in her case is fix
her broken brain to bring her back to a
healthy brain and that means you
actually have to know what you're doing
right as opposed to just having a really
big simulator if you had enough euros
and a patient enough European Union
right you could just keep pumping money
into it so you had this huge
supercomputer and if you only knew
physics and knew nothing about how
brains worked but you had a good enough
electron microscope and a big enough
supercomputer you could imagine
simulating her diseased brain but if you
want to fix her diseased brain so it's
not diseased anymore now yeah it you
have to know how brains work right and
that's in my opinion centuries off at
best you want to add anything to that
I guess just on the last plate I mean I
think you bring up an interesting
question is it harder to fix a brain a
broken brain than to construct one I
don't know if you've ever worked with
somebody's code it's kind of easier to
make a new code but on the other hand it
in you know
epilepsy it actually on some level you
don't have to understand the brain and
they can actually take out chunks of
brain and because there's extreme
plasticity or adaptability of the brain
it fixes itself so maybe it is it easier
problem actually to fix a brain if you
can harness these these plasticity so
when you refer to something in your
slides about you had a nice slide with a
brain on one side and a circuit board on
the other so there's the idea that we
might see all the circuits we could
reconstruct all the circuits for
somebody and and then perhaps that would
be sufficient to give us some insight
into their cognitive processes but you
made this distinction between the
circuits and the minds can you tell me -
tell us elaborate that on that a little
bit so even if we get the circuits
what's different about the mind so in
that first slide that I showed you the
thought was no it's okay if you remember
the two brains right so the thought was
that not all circuitry is going to give
rise to a mind or consciousness and so
there's one question what's special
about certain circuits because you don't
you know go from you can't just read off
if you'd like brain circuitry and say oh
we have consciousness there right sir
well it's a very hard problem to
understand how to show those connections
in a way that's informative you can
understand why there's a mind there so
in that sense brain doesn't equal mind
because certain parts of the brain don't
give rise to the mind that of course
file is consistent saying what obligate
which is I think most of us believe
which is of course the brain of the mind
is dependent on the brain you know I
think in these sort of reconstruction
ideas the idea of preserving brain
function and hoping that in the future
someone can reconstruct your mind you
know it does bring us back to the
Turing's test and sort of how you would
know that you've been successful because
you've physically duplicated the brain
that's sufficient to get right give rise
to the same mind
is it sufficient to give rise to a mind
let's say that the technology requires
not that we do it in organic materials
but it's a lot easier to do it in
organic materials and you know the same
questions are going to rise so I think
that's the gap right about thinking
about a physical system like a circuit
board there or the organic system on the
other side and recognizing that there
aren't any sort of easy or clear
connections that link those physical
systems to the mental system the
consciousness system issue so on it
maybe you can tell us exactly where do
these sort of close enough sums where do
they start to fall short right so you
know we could build a brain from the
bottom up by knowing all the circuits
and then replicating them their function
in silico for example and then hoping
that that somehow is going to give rise
to correct responses and thinks it might
be generative and witty and intelligent
but where are we now and where where do
things really fall short and what what's
the solution going to be to some of
these tough questions so I think the
place is what we're falling short are or
that you see the biggest gaps are when
you are looking for to represent a
specific individual it's certainly much
easier to represent a general behavior
or a general type of behavior an angry
person or a sad person or a happy person
people with particular kinds of affect
people that you've never met before like
that like the gentleman who was a
Holocaust survivor or this virtual
therapist there we tend to do better at
because we can say well they're at least
close to somebody I know and I can kind
of relate to them but certainly we're
nowhere close to being able to represent
a specific individual in any it to any
degree and I don't know as Wayne was
talking I was trying to think you know
what would it take to start to represent
that individual and you know that
difference between mind and brain I
think is crucial here and just because
someone say can think like someone I
know does that make them that person or
do they need to have access to all of
those memories what happens
those memories when you replicate the
brain are you still getting access to
those memories I have no idea so I think
memory is maybe a different subset of
that that might be interesting for us to
discuss
but sandy I wanted to talk to you I
wanted you to tell us a little bit about
what are we learning from the biology
that helps these guys right because some
of this investment it's not necessarily
about replicating you know our
consciousness or Henry's consciousness
Henry Markram is consciousness or the
consciousness of a rat that you know
who's whose brain they're reconstructing
but hopefully along the way we'll sort
of meet some milestones that will kind
of make things better for cognitive
computing so is there a dialogue you
know what what are what can we learn
from studying these small circuits
that's going to enable or facilitate
improvements in what computer scientists
can do there might be two ways to answer
the question so okay do we need to
funnel our data into a Henry Markram
simulation environment and then it goes
to AI folks that's one possibility and
that could perform some certain checks
because again if if a simulation becomes
sufficient to recapitulate things that
we've observed that's satisfying and
that might be a limit test like okay
feed that on up to AI or we could
potentially skip the in silico
and just try it in our own labs are we
identifying some principles so when
thinking of going from brain to mind
even in our own living States we have
periods of sleep we're not conscious and
we're awake and we're conscious and I
mentioned the introduction that is
correlated with kind of brain patterns
and that you have highly synchronized
neural activities when you're sleeping
and D synchronize and awake maybe those
are some clues another another clue is
actually in the visual system you are
getting light information that goes to
your unconscious brain your hypothalamus
about light levels and that's what in
trains our circadian rhythms when we
literally have a little biological clock
that we are not consciously aware of
so if you're late at night getting blue
light from from your computer screens
unconsciously a lot of brain activities
going on and response to that blue light
but at the same time we're looking
around the room navigating walking up
and down the stairs pulling down the
seat and sitting and those are your
conscious vision and and maybe just more
carefully studying the differences
between those brain processes in the lab
could help inform yeah I don't know so
right now most of the flow is from
computer science to neuroscience and not
the other way we we get inspiration from
the fact that there are brains out there
but and the neuro scientists if they if
they just do their thing which is
looking at things you can measure in a
neuroscience lab they don't really know
what they're looking at at that higher
level so what the computer scientists
have been doing is trying everything
they can think of right Oh fractals
sound good let's try that how about
chaos theory
how about hopfield nets how about back
propagation that's how about production
systems they try all this crazy stuff
and it turns out the good news is that
some of its actually useful so you can
build useful stuff which may not tell
you anything about the brain but you can
make money that way but they're also
saying gee I wonder if this is in the
brain aren't any for any X you can pick
there's some paper about oh I found X in
the brain I found chaotic I found
hausdorff dimension two pi two point
five chaotic attractors in the rabbit
olfactory ball right so eventually
what's gonna happen is we're gonna turn
a corner we're not there yet we're gonna
turn a corner where eventually
neuroscience is going to start telling
computer scientists useful stuff that
really is in the brain right we're not
there yet
in part because it's very hard to see
enough right you can record from with
few neurons at once we can record from a
million neurons at once the story's
going to be really different but right
now a lot of the ideas generation comes
from the computer scientists trying any
kind of crazy thing they can think of
and then hoping that the neuroscientist
can can use that language to talk about
what they're seeing I would say also I
think it's important to remember that
you know brains are biological systems
that evolved with lots of constraints
and so the way they do things may not be
the best way to accomplish cognition it
just is the
local minima that they've settled into
and so it might it might be that there's
inspiration from the biology but it
might also be that the biology will lead
you down some some false roads and that
it's not necessarily useful sandy you
and I were talking earlier on about
disease and and if for example we're not
going to understand neural circuits in
order to build a better computer or have
sort of avatars that interact with us as
if they're humans
what's the what's the next best thing
that we're going to get out of this
understanding the biological sure and
that that's definitely a goal of lots of
neuroscience lab AI has a goal of maybe
making some money maybe we could make
some contributions to translational
research and again looking at these vary
in the cell type-specific weight
understanding what is this neuron type
doing is it specifically broken in a
disease can we rescue just the function
of one neuron class and then fix the
whole problem and actually that there
are becoming more and more examples of I
just want to add one thing if you want
one example where the theory actually is
proved valuable it's a tractor neural
networks if you look up with tractor
neural networks people have found good
evidence for them in multiple brain
areas so it's not it's not wishful
thinking people really believe that
there aren't attractor networks in the
brain I wish there were more success
stories like that but at least we have
one so I I'm gonna ask one more question
before opening it up to all of you to
talk to the panelists here but I want to
get back to mine because in some sense
right what we really value about each
other is is that is consciousness right
is the ability to interact with another
mind where you can see that insight and
you feel that connection and so you know
we might have a lot of circuits but the
mind is something that might be a little
bit different how necessary is it for us
will can we succeed without mine and I'd
like to address that to the philosopher
here
No so I mean sure if this poor woman who
died of brain tumor if there was some
way to have preserved her the structures
in her brain that we all agree were
sufficient to give rise to her unique
mind you know if you were able to
simulate that somehow and there plenty
of science fiction movies that involve
this sort of idea you're able to kind of
replicate that you might still feel
uncomfortable as one of her loved ones
interacting with a system that you
somehow downloaded her thoughts and
memories into you know circuit board
there that is now producing responses
like she would have if she was still
alive and this is the value of mine
right this is the question about whether
you've done it successfully like is it
enough just that you've simulated past
rings test so that the hardest turned
testament pass would be having her
interact with her loved ones
it's one thing to interact with the sort
of objective judge he doesn't really
know her but if she could even do that I
mean you might just feel and this is
probably what some of you feel about
during stress that it's just mere
simulation it would only be a kind of
replica of her kind of you know Xerox
copy and that's just not valuable enough
even if you agree that she had in mind
it would just be it would either be that
she doesn't really have one system it's
not she's not there or if in a sense do
it then it's a mine but it's not really
her so these are really hard questions
that sort of push us the ethics and our
values of how we value individuals and
social interactions and I think those
are questions that we don't immediately
think about right because one of the
questions that we want to deal with here
it's how to even just get to that point
where you think you might but it's got
broader ramifications and I think that's
important too soon so I'd like to take
this opportunity now to let people in
the audience ask questions and I think
we can pass her on the mic just so that
everybody can hear so back here Jim well
we're taping it might be useful thank
you
thanks for the comments I think this is
really fascinating stuff so my question
is sort of I killed on the last set of
comments and thinking about the you look
at a brain or you look at a computer and
from the outside you couldn't possibly
know what's going on and it's kind of a
an issue of accumulated experience over
time that's what makes us all
individuals so I'm wondering if you
could address something about this is
more really for the neuroscientists is
that accumulated experience something
that is being explored do we understand
how a brain in a mind develops based on
what they're exposed to over the court
life history of their experience to
understand how memory works do we
understand how these kind of things can
be recalled to do we have two rats that
have exactly the same experiences and
have exactly the same brain there's kind
of two fields of studies that are
addressing that one is something called
critical period plasticity this idea
that your early life experiences during
this especially in particular when
you're young have a very potent impact
on brain function and Wilkin based on
how that impact is you will further set
kind of your lifelong learning and yeah
there's research going on here and many
universities on this critical period
plasticity in terms of memory that's
typically studied unfortunately
fortunately by a different set of
neuroscientists and that's thought to a
lot of attention is put into the
hippocampus a specific brain region and
understanding how you first recognize
kind of a novel scenario you store that
information and then you have to
consolidate and ship that information
into different brain areas so it's a
quite a bit of work is going on on those
levels yeah I would just add I think one
of the really interesting things about
trying to see the physical changes that
happen
in memory for example requires not only
a structural understanding of how
neurons talk to each other
but there's a number of other dynamic
things that are happening for example
sandy mentioned circadian rhythms right
you have all these sort of hormonal
influences neuromodulators epigenetic
modifications to DNA that change the
responsibility of a cell and so it's the
information is not just contained in the
structure it's contained in the dynamics
as well and so it might be that to
capture all of that you need not only a
physical anatomical circuit sort of
diagram but you also need to know
something about how those pieces worked
with each other which can be very
individual other questions that's it
yeah I just follow on your last comments
and I think currently we are assuming
everything on a deterministic framework
so essentially we're thinking of four
connectivity's determines where the
consciousness come from but what if
that's not the case what if the is a
dynamic as the moderator just point out
that conscious where the consciousness
come from then all the brain circuitry
and hoping that the circuitry were
determined where the memory forms it's
always the role of window and it doesn't
work that way
III think this is a question for Wayne
really sort of Cartesian you know can we
can we take the brain and extract from
that something that's sort of more
dynamic was it a question for me well so
the thought was I guess if I understand
we've been focusing on something more
static in a sense of connections and the
thought was that if you could reproduce
that that would be enough to reproduce
consciousness and then the alternative
think thought was that well you have to
think about the dynamic aspects of it
and that might not follow from simply
just looking at the connections
something to that effect
that might be right I mean this question
about going from either these two cases
to consciousness and the mind I think
what I meant earlier when I said you
know those bridges are not so clear it's
partly informed by these you know three
possibilities right it's not going to be
easy to answer how something like
consciousness comes about it may be that
thinking to statically about it may not
be the right way to go about it so in
that sense I agree I think I think the
possibility is how to explain how you
get a mind or consciousness from a
physical structure like out of these two
cases I think it's an open question so I
think that's right I'm at least we
should be open to these alternatives so
I have a point and a question well so
the first one is uh actually read
Turing's original article the
description of the imitation game was
not like the end-all be-all
you know definition of consciousness it
was a minimum barrier of entry to an
intelligent machine and you know somehow
the Turing test has been morphed into
this ultimatum that once we pass it we
will have you know computerised
consciousness but that's not what Turing
intended so we we kind of are relying in
this old way of thinking about
intelligence and consciousness that I
think is biasing where the discussion
and where our research is going that was
my my point my question is that when
we're talking about things like
consciousness memory you know perception
these are kind of philosophical
constructs that have very difficult
operational definitions so where can we
find a bridge between the operationalize
terms like what sandy uses with you know
finally very specific stimuli to engage
very specific neural and nizam Buhl's
and something like memory or
decision-making where can we start to
build those bridges so something about
the point so that's right I mean I gave
you turns original question which was
can machines think and the beauty of
what he did was to say I'm gonna change
that question and I'm gonna provide you
the test for that and I think I I meant
in some ways Tim to sort of leave open
the issues that you just raised in terms
of that point which is
you know if you don't like that test if
that's not the appropriate task we need
to come up with another and I think your
question which is about operationalizing
something so if you want a definition of
consciousness you're not going to find
one okay
I just just pulled this plug here I
asked Wayne earlier on if you could
provide a definition of consciousness
and he said no right so there is no but
I would also I would also point out that
to study a lot of things in natural
science you don't need it to find them
right if you're if you're observing
Tigers you don't that tell me exactly
what a tiger is as long as you can track
it so I think if we're studying
consciousness which seems kind of
ineffable in some ways because it's
really hard to describe no one's got a
definition of it it might be enough that
you can track it so if you want to study
imagery some of you have studied all
right as long as you can generate images
consistently and you can report that
that might be enough to get at that
right at least to see coral it's so
definitions are not going to be present
for that but I think you're right I mean
that these open this challenge of how
then do we base our understanding of
mental phenomenon in a way that we you
know good work and connecting then the
brain or artificial sir yeah systems to
that I don't have an answer that Jim but
I think it's good to highlight that
that's part of the major challenge that
question over here I think is the money
yes this is certainly this is a pull up
and I hope you'll forgive me I will
formulate my question um is this better
yeah okay so I'm gonna formulate my
question on the fly and I'll also first
make a point and then ask a question
it'll be easier for me this way so
regarding the Turing test one of the
things that always have bothered me
about it is not so much the machines
that do not pass the test that human
beings like let's say human being
doesn't pass the Turing test what does
this mean I mean I'm sure that there are
plenty of them that do not and then what
does this mean do they not have mind the
consciousness and then starting to think
about this a bit
more we're using these constructs like
memory perception but there are
individuals for example who lose all of
their memory and there are individuals
who for example do not have visual
perception at least sometimes they do
not have even tactile perception but
they could potentially still be aware
right there could still be consciousness
there and from Phylis so both
philosophical and I guess neuroscience
perspective what have how do you think
what happens once you read reduce I mean
essentially an electronic brain is the
brain that doesn't receive necessarily
visual input other kinds of input that
might not have memory to start with
memory of specific events so what's left
then guess that's my question so it's
it's not clear that a human being who
never had any sensory input would be
recognizable as human people who in
adulthood lose say vision or hearing or
boat they stole their minds were formed
by their sensory experiences and so then
you can say well they're you know
they're aware they just can't
communicate at least through those
modalities but if you took something if
you took a human baby and this is a
horrible thing to think about and
disconnected it from sensory input it's
unlikely that it would even survive
right and if it did if you were able to
keep it alive it's unlikely that would
develop in a way that we'd be
recognizably human so I'm not sure it
makes sense to say that somebody could
fail the Turing test because they're
they're blind or deaf well the Turing
test is just it's a suggestive of a way
of demonstrating mental capacity right
and if you if you can't see well then
we'll give you the test or auditorally
and if you can't see we're here then
we'll do it by tapping on your skin
right but if you can if there's some way
that you can demonstrate complex mental
processes you could in theory pass the
Turing test but if there's nothing there
right if you've then
just disconnected from the sensorium
from from conception and there's just
nothing there and the fact that you have
the same chromosome count as everybody
else doesn't really make you human in my
opinion can I just add something to that
but which is um I think the thing about
you're worried about the test is that
it's not meant passing it is not meant
to be a necessary condition for having a
mind so if you fail that that doesn't
show that you're you're lacking a mind
right so but going back to a lot of
issues that have come up is it
sufficient well yeah if something passed
it you might really think very hard
about whether or not that system has a
mind but if you don't like the test I go
back to this issue of like yeah let's
think hard about you know how are we
going to test for success in replicating
conscious vision or you know being able
to imagine something or just being able
to do you know math in a way that humans
do do math in a way that involves a mind
as opposed to merely just like
simulating it like so maybe you know the
jeopardy champion does certain things
but the way he or she does it is going
to involve lots of mental processing and
they meant that might not have been
replicated in in these systems that
outperform human beings so you know what
tests are we gonna replace turns tests
with if we don't like it so I think
that's an important question to keep in
mind I think we have time for one last
question so two last questions okay oh
thank you for taking the question and
coming one and possible answer I've read
about for an alternative to the Turing
test was called the Lovejoy test asking
the computer to be creative write a poem
write a song don't just respond make
something on your own the question I had
for Sandy from a neurobiological point
of view is is need function of in other
words necessity is the mother of
invention do we need something we need
to live we need to survive do neurons
behave differently if they're hungry you
know or they want or they're lonely
you know can I write a computer program
when I threatened to pull the plug he's
gonna start answering the questions
properly you know so is need and
integral parts of artificial
intelligence thank you so I can start
off the answer to that question and
maybe link back to what Tim was talking
about a little bit with decision so
certainly if an animal at least the
rodent that we study in the lab is
hungry he will do very different things
than if he's he's not so clearly that in
terms of the biological brain that is
fundamental to decision-making so a
choice of whether to go out and forage
during the day which would normally not
be a safe time there are animals more
apt to do dangerous things if it's
hungry so we know that's how biology or
brains work I don't know is there is
that is it necessary to incorporate that
into machine
you probably program it in right yeah I
mean if we imagine that we don't have
the compute power to represent the brain
and so that we're sort of optimizing how
we're leveraging that computing power
and there's this threat essentially to
its performance then it can sort of
shift to call it spending it's computing
power more towards this but I think the
question is is much more subtle I don't
think so I really just don't think so
ok so I have another potential kind of
test to replace the Turing test know if
something is is in fact sentient or
conscious so basically it's a kind of
know it when you see it thing where
right now we have I don't like the
pornography test no I I know it's the
same words but it's a different meaning
I'm so I'm a fallibilist
so I believe that knowledge consists of
explanation so if we knew what
consciousness was and and we knew how to
what the algorithmic
was behind it we could explain it so
right now because we're lacking the
knowledge we're looking for some
empirical tests but this is not really
an empirical thing in the same way that
if you're thinking about pure math it's
not empirical right something what makes
up a triangle or what makes up
consciousness is something that you you
understand in a in a knowledgeable way
so we know for example that a
intelligence system would have to have
some kind of representation for
knowledge and we know that for for a
conscious to be conscious like a human
you must have sense perceptions so
qualia and we don't really have very
good definitions for these things but if
we found the algorithmic process then we
would be able to create a definition and
we would know what that was and we would
know it was conscious and if we found a
definition for that then we could
definitely create an algorithmic process
and then we can use the definition to
show that the algorithmic process
achieves it and then we would also know
that that was sentient so panelists you
have a opinion about that I think it's
some sense I guess back to the isness
pornography question I don't know how
we'd get to that definition that would
be sufficient for us to create the
algorithmic process
I don't know how others feel on this
panel I think that's a that would be a
huge challenge that I don't think we're
prepared to answer at least at this
point so I think the word consciousness
is like the word cool it's a it's a
social construct and not physically
measurable phenomenon and so
consciousness is what we define it to be
all right we have one last question here
um I have a very simple question because
I'm a layman and my understanding is
that Homo sapiens somewhere around 70
million years ago developed the ability
to think abstractly cognizance I guess
you can call it forgetting about
computers I'm not sure who's who here in
terms of neurological work or research
but I'd like to ask the most basic
question of all do we have any hints
what we we seem to know quite a bit
through imagery about objective actions
that we take physical actions do we have
any hints whatsoever about anything
having to do with studying abstract
thinking whatsoever forget about memory
and anything whatsoever that for the
future you see us going into that
direction that's again I'm a layman and
I'm just asking a really very simple
question I don't want to so a good
example of abstract thinking is
reasoning about numbers and there is a
lot of literature on the development of
numerous saying in kids
I don't know that literature or we
should have had a psychologist on the
panel as well but that's that's a place
I think you could look for development
of abstract reasoning at all
developmental processing in kids has
been studied extensively we're not born
able to reason abstractly and they don't
really get good at it until high school
like the brain circuitry of the stands
psychology but do we have any hints as
to future research in terms of studying
the brain the brain's ability to think
abstractly
not from a psychological point but so I
um I imagine that the way to study that
right now the best technology now would
be fMRI studies of people engaged in
abstract functional magnetic resonance
imaging
so actually what one of the slides that
Wayne showed had some fMRI images of a
brain and the one where the person heard
the sound versus didn't hear the sound
in different parts of the brain were
lighting up so that seems to be the if
you wanted to study that kind of thing
and I think people are that would be the
way to do it right now is that this
gross level of what parts of the brain
are lighting up and what parts aren't so
I want to take this opportunity to thank
our panelists I think it's been a really
stimulating discussion and invite you
all to a reception outside the room here
so thanks everybody